okay representative dan crenshaw is on
the house energy and commerce committee
he's a former navy seal and he joins us
live right now to talk about a plethora
of things starting with that report from
bill molusion these border patrol agents
they'll get they'll get no penalty or
they were frowned to have not done what
they were accused of but they're still
going to have a penalty how do we make
sense of that
well apparently jesse smallett's a
special advisor
all right and uh you know you know i i
guess they all they probably yell this
is mega country as these asian migrants
were rushing across the border illegally
invading our country
um look this is this is just yet another
another reason why this administration
is deliberately violating the
constitution by refusing to execute our
laws and what you're seeing here is that
joe biden came out and said look we're
not going to defund the police that's
not the democrat policy but he has every
intention of degrading law enforcement
degrading federal law enforcement
degrading our military making sure that
they're completely ineffective so so
some democrats say it out loud defund
the police but the rest of the democrats
say well we're not defending the police
they just wanted to grade them entirely
i mean at every single level until our
laws are just not forced at all and they
get what they want which is an
effectively an open border
and it's textbook congressman it's uh
it's six months later or whatever it is
it's a friday afternoon dump an
admission that they didn't do anything
wrong yet they're still facing
administrative action
what does this do you know to people
hoping that there could be sanity on our
border or for border patrol agents still
working down there what does a result
like this mean
yeah and that's what i mean by degrading
because what you're doing is completely
demoralizing the border patrol they're
already demoralized why would anybody
join border patrol at this point what is
their recruitment going to be like here
moving forward this is not a it's not an
easy job to begin with and that's if
your administration actually lets you do
it
and and tells you you're actually going
to get to do what you signed up for and
be rewarded for it so so let's get this
straight you have a border you have this
entity called the border patrol which is
designed to protect it okay they carry
guns they carry handcuffs they they
carry all the attributes of law
enforcement
and then they enforce the law by simply
blockading people rushing across our
border and then our government punishes
them for it
this is this is beyond reproach this is
an insane thing and this will be one of
the first things that we conduct
oversight on specifically when we retake
the house well you're coming to us from
texas and karine jean-pierre says that
the state of texas needs to stay out of
immigration take a listen and i want to
get your reaction on the other side
i'll say this the immigration
enforcement is a federal authority uh
and states should not be mandating it
meddling in it that is just especially
uh governor
texas governor of abbott who has a track
record of causing chaos and confusion at
the border so i would refer you to doj
on any legal matter
but again this is an immigration
enforcement enforcement is a federal
authority
congressman your thoughts
um well as the saying goes you can go to
hell i'm going to texas
but maybe she should come to texas and
and see it for herself yes this is where
the crisis is for her
their actions that this administration's
actions are causing a crisis in texas
and especially in these southern border
counties this is this is incredibly
unfair to us in texas we've spent
billions upon billions of dollars over
the years trying to fix the federal
government's border problem governor
abbott is doing everything he can within
the law to to at least try to dissent
disincentivize these illegals coming
across our border in droves i mean look
we're almost at a million crossings just
this year this is this is this is
unprecedented this is a crisis in full
form and look remember obama's dhs
secretary jay johnson said 1 000 a day
would be considered crisis and they're
doing nothing to stop this governor
rabbit is doing what he can hopefully
it's effective
but for them to chastise him for it
again it just shows it just shows that
they are controlled by radical
immigration groups everything they do
demonstrates that they are controlled by
radical immigration groups real quick
congressman should should the governor
declare it an invasion which would open
up
constitutional avenues for the state
look there's arguments for that there's
arguments against that it's it's tough
to read the constitution that way and
that's what it meant um but it might be
getting to this point where we have no
choice now the problem the governor has
with that
is he's actually putting his agents his
dps agents uh his state troopers in
jeopardy because they could in theory be
violating a federal law and be arrested
this is this is a difficult situation
and it's the federal government's job to
do it it's it's so unbelievably
frustrating look i'm working on a
variety of pieces of legislation that
directly fix this problem with our with
the abuse of our asylum process of the
flores settlement which has caused most
of this um labeling these cartels as
trans national criminal organizations
which gives additional authorities to
actually deal with them there are things
that the federal government needs to be
doing democrats just don't want to do it
sounds like you're outlining immigration
reform which has been a fun thing to say
for 20 years if you can get some headway
on it you've got you've got my support
on that
moving on to another topic that's also
very germane to texas the gop is
hammering biden forget this allowing our
energy our oil reserve strategic
petroleum reserve to go to china and
europe uh what's your take on this and
what's the story here
well the the oil market is complicated
first of all biden's policies of
releasing oil from strategic reserve
are it's just a gimmick those aren't my
words actually that's that's president
obama's words when he was asked to do
this it's a gimmick it doesn't really
affect prices and it takes away from our
reserve our reserve is not there to to
affect price mechanisms it is there in
case we say you know have a giant
hurricane on the gulf coast and we need
to tap into this because refineries are
down all right that that's what it's for
um it is not for this and here's the
here's the worst part about this this
china deal they coordinated with china
asking china to also release reserves so
there would be a global release it would
have it would have more of an effect
what did china do
go back on the deal and actually buy up
almost barrel for barrel exactly what we
released so so because they don't
produce anything so of course they're
going to continue to build out their
reserves while we try and do supposedly
the right thing and do this but but we
do have to be careful when we criticize
exports because exports are what drive
production if when we lifted the export
ban it drove gas prices down um so if
you want to send the signal for more
production you do have to encourage
exports
it just seems like so many of the
solutions that the biden administration
has for inflation whether it's removing
the tariffs on china or selling them
this oil instead of so it was supposedly
supposed to help drive down the cost um
and and have more oil here um in in the
united states it just seems like so many
things are in china's favor which then
brings us back to hunter biden's laptop
and the kind and the and the very
compromising deals the information that
the chinese have on our president um
could any of this be behind some of
these policies that always tend to
benefit china to the you know
and not the american people who whose
side is this guy on
yeah i mean it's an open question and
it's obviously worth investigating again
one of the priorities i think for our
oversight committees um when we retake
the majority because right now we just
have no power to do that but we will
when we win in november again it's
important that people get out and vote
because this this is potential
corruption more and more keeps coming
out on hunter biden um is there there
there is that why this happened and we
don't know but these things are worth
investigating
absolutely uh one more topic we want to
get to this morning congressman the u.s
army set a deadline of june 30th for all
soldiers in the guard and reserve to be
vaccinated while 60 000 soldiers have
refused and the administration's
attempting to crack down on them by
removing pay and they won't be able to
do federal service
what do you make of this we're already
short on recruitment now you're going to
potentially push out or not pay 60 000
guardsmen and reservists
what does this do to our readiness
well it's terrible for our readiness
we've long had trouble with recruitment
and but there's a variety of reasons for
that i think the primary reason is that
the warrior culture that was that was so
intrinsic to the military for so long
is is being is being deliberately
depleted by this administration
and i think patriotic young men and
women are seeing that and they're
thinking i i don't want to join this
military right they're seeing the low
morale they're seeing what they're used
for it's just it's just not a good place
and then you have this on top of it and
so what i've said about the vaccine
issue is this look it is true that we
have long been told you will take
vaccines in the military and there's
nothing you can do about it um law or
lawful orders and good discipline
uh and bearing in a military is
extremely important it falls apart
otherwise that being said it is worth
noting to dod leadership that this
particular vaccine was controversial
okay it's brand new it did get
politicized and whether you agree with
the with the with the idea that it's
harmful or not at least that we can
agree on the single fact that it's
simply controversial and so now as a
leader you have to make a decision do
you and you have to weigh costs and
benefits is it worth putting your foot
down in this case and potentially
hurting your readiness which is a far
greater threat to the military
and and the country
just to you know
just just to just to make a political
statement and the thing is is that
they've also effectively taken religious
exemptions off the table they long gave
religious exemptions for vaccines but
here they they give so few that they've
effectively taken that option off the
table and the last thing is you don't
need to punish people to this extent all
right if you if you want to make a point
like fine you make them non-deployable
you can hurt someone's career a little
bit but keep them in when we need good
people instead they kick people out in
droves and
hurt our readiness it's just it's
unbelievable congressman i personally
know
multiple young men strapping awesome
young men who wanted to become navy
seals who said i'm not joining the
military because i already got coveted
and i don't want to take the vaccine and
also the signaling of all this wokeness
going on they're just getting
it's repelling to them they don't want
to they don't want to join and we would
normally have these guys america needs
them and i just think that perhaps this
vaccine mandate and and the severity of
the punishments is definitely meant to
keep young men like that out i i i can't
believe why they wouldn't want people
like that
yeah look exactly and it's a variety of
factors right it's it's this woke
training that you see this sort of
diversity inclusion training it's a
marine corps putting rainbow colors on
their on their helmet and stuff instead
of just focusing on war you know and and
look i think the vast vast majority of
people in the military want to focus on
war if anybody asks me i say
and they want a career in the military i
say yes you should absolutely go look
it's still worth it
because look in in the end a lot of this
stuff is far and few between
but but
it's it's what makes the headlines and
it's hurting our recruiting and our
leaders need to stand up to it there's
no there is no benefit in this nonsense
training there's no benefit making
people sit at a computer for hours at a
time doing what's called these gmts
these general military instruction
trainings
it's there's no point to it right p p
you know what i'm talking about
it's it is and joey does too i mean we
wasted so much of our time in the
military doing this stuff and that was
before it got really woke imagine what
it's like now
i see that i see that marine corps hate
there you're going to lean in on the
army guys it's true it's the box
checking all across the board but now
you're box checking on nonsense uh and
indoctrination which is even scary
moving from china this big threat in
china and now we're talking about our
military going to kick 60 000 because
they didn't take a controversial do you
want your entire military to take a
vaccine for which there has never been a
long-term study that's another national
security
thank you congressman carson thank you
thank you